[Music]
from the aristocrats who awaited
Mozart's latest compositions to the pop
charts of today from our desire for the
latest fashions to our focus on the
latest film or book the new has driven
music and culture for hundreds of years
but that was in an era where access to
art was limited now we potentially have
access to everything music from every
culture and era every style every film
every book in this unparalleled space
should we escape the tyranny of the new
and seek out the best from unknown and
uncelebrated places from distant lands
and other times is art not about the
novel but about lasting value or is the
new they limited by place and time
necessarily more vital than the past and
we have an incredibly brilliantly vital
panel to attend to these themes
I have Clare van Campen on my far right
Clare is a director composer and Olivier
and Tony Award nominated playwrights she
became the first musical director of
both the Royal Shakespeare Company and
the National Theatre and she was the
founding director of the globe and Clare
has recently been awarded an honorary
Doctorate from Brunel University I have
a mark earlier here whose the Guardians
global music critic he's also written
further times that we supplement clash
and he also plays the drums for the band
home arose and is publishing a
collection of poetry soft punch scene I
have Brian Eno on the far left who is a
musician record producer visual artist
and theorist best known for his
pioneering work in ambient music and his
contributions to rock pop and
electronica and earlier this year Brian
received the Stephen Hawking medal for
science communication and here I have
Sophie finds he's a filmmaker
Sophie's films include
operation with Slava jiseok the perverts
guide to cinema also over your city's
grass will grow and most recently blood
lights and bam II in which Sookie worked
with Grace Jones over a period of 12
years and the significant question I'll
go to clear van kampen first is for
three minutes should we escape the
tyranny of the new Clare thank you well
tyranny what does it mean I think it's
had several different meanings in my
lifetime but the dictionary definition
of tyranny is cruel unreasonable or
arbitrary use of power and control I
think one of the great benefits of being
able to share in a world together a
world of the ether like the Internet is
that we're making decisions for
ourselves about what grip we choose to
be in I could say that in my lifetime
there was sort of two waves of tyranny
first I suppose you could say in the 50s
it was the housewife who was told she
should buy the latest vacuum clean in
the latest kitchen maker the this for
that it was a subtle and seditious form
of tyranny that was very imprisoning and
then later in the 80s came market forces
you need this you need that you need it
now needs to be new you need to throw
this away it doesn't matter I think
we're very in a very exciting new
dialogue with what we need to live and I
would say that art has always been part
of a dialogue of social change and so if
if we're in a conversation with what's
new certainly an art we're in a
conversation with how we're changing as
a society and social change to me I
think is has never been as exciting as
it is now I think in terms of new what
do we mean by new do we mean instant
or do we mean discovery the whole of our
landscape is changing certainly in my
line of work I had no idea that Mozart
for example who most of us have heard of
was actually inspired by a guy that was
the son of a slave owner in the
Caribbean came to Paris wrote stunning
music almost self-taught brilliant
Olympic level fencer dancer and he was
called him Joseph Klein
he has been rather crudely labeled as
the black Mozart which i think is not a
very helpful label but what's
interesting that we are finding out that
there are all kinds of people men and
women that created art and contributed
to arts that we before the internet and
before scholars were able to dig into
research these people were lost
undiscovered now our landscape is
completely changed so I would say that
I'm very excited by what we call new if
it means that we're bringing into our
landscape all these new and newly
discovered people that enrich and change
the way we think about music and art
Thank You Collier for the same question
and I should we escape the tyranny of
the new no I don't think so do you want
to expect yeah I will I think that I
don't in the new is tyrannical really at
all I think that everything new well I
think it's impossible to create anything
in a vacuum I think everything new is
kind of in constant dialogue with the
past and I think that whatever is new
and was being created now can be a kind
of a great gateway for people to get to
more marginalized stories and voices and
I think that actually maybe we don't
give enough credit people who are
creating now in terms of the sort of
research and work that they do into
making whatever it is that they're doing
so I think
she does Marietta references that kind
of come through and I think the great
contextual sort of realm of the Internet
can be really useful for that because
you can kind of get to a new artist and
then you can kind of look through let's
say Wikipedia or Spotify biographies and
then have this kind of information
cascade where you're suddenly clicking
from link to link to link and you're
discovering stuff from way before which
you never knew about before and which
even the artist might have unwittingly
kind of imbibed into whatever their
practice is so I think in that respect
the new is kind of trivial things really
kind of vibrant and exciting I also
think if you take it from the other
perspective and let's say we don't
prioritize the new as much and we we
slowly kind of look to the past to try
and on earth marginalize figures who
kind of were not represented you're
equally then turning your back on what
is I think actually quite a radical
platform now for marginalized diverse
voices today so you're kind of playing a
zero-sum game where you're not really
kind of engaging with marginality now in
favor of engaging with it in the past
eunice as a concept I think is always
going to be tied towards will kind of
tie to commercial drives and difference
and I think that's always going to be a
kind of difficult relationship to have
with the way that we consume we're
always going to have the new shoved down
our throats but I think in and amongst
that that can be really exciting space I
think actually to kind of engage with
difference that doesn't just mean it's
not commercial it's something else it's
kind of existing on the periphery and
that can be fresh and exciting thank you
so the same question to Brian Eno Brian
should we escape it's here any of the
new this is such a difficult question
because there are two terms in it that
are difficult to understand one is
tyranny and the other is new so I'll
assume that we could come to some
agreement about tyranny but I bet you we
would all disagree about what new means
and one of the problems is that humans
are constantly innovating all humans are
makers of newness for example that last
sentence I said has possibly never been
said before and probably you will well
each of us in this room would make at
least 50 or 70 sentences today that
nobody has ever said before that that
means we are all of us new and creative
and I had a shocking experience a few
years back there was a show of early to
early 20th century Russian painting at
the Barbican which was an area that I
kind of specialized in art school it was
the area that I thought I knew most
about and I went along to the show and
discovered that out of the 160 or so
artists there there were about 70 I had
never heard of and they were just as
good as the ones I had heard of and and
I suddenly realized of course that
history dropped certain people out and
elevate some names beyond others rather
like you were saying that there are all
these people get forgotten but so then I
came up with this idea which I will
introduce quite quickly because I don't
want to take over here we're very used
in the West the idea of genius the idea
that there are certain people who are
very very gifted and and they're thought
sort of trickle down to the rest of us
and we list those people like Mozart and
Beethoven and Darwin and Einstein and so
on to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas